Why are all these features missing from high-end cameras the technology already exists in our hands in these cameras.
Why isn't it there in the professional cameras? Tinfoil hat time!
It is the year 2020, there's not a better time to be alive if you're an independent filmmaker, but you know what?
Professional cameras they are still severely lacking in certain features that they really should have by this time
Because right here in these cheap cameras features that these cameras are missing this camera right here is a twenty thousand dollar camera
And if it had some of the features that this GoPro had it would change my life
But it doesn't right now it's more of a hindrance than a help and tools here are supposed to help us create art not get
In the way, so let's find out what these problems are that I hope Karen makers solve in 2020
Right now both GoPros and your phone have little gyroscopes and accelerometers
built into them so they can kind of tell how they're moving what their
orientation is and what kind of g-forces they're experiencing that information can then be parsed by a program to give
Opposite movement to your footage to cancel out any bumps or shakes in your footage
That's why GoPro shots are so smooth
now these days if you want to stabilize your footage and you're not treating on something like a phone or a GoPro you have to
do it optically in other words a
Program has to follow the points in your picture track them and then try to undo that motion
So for example, if we're getting a shot at me right now talking and the cameras all shaky
But I'm in the foreground and I'm moving to it's going to track me
It's not going to get the right motion to eliminate the shake
This problem has been solved and consumer devices like your phones, consumer devices like your GoPro and yet here is a twenty thousand dollar camera
That doesn't have that same solution. In fact, you can go out there
You can buy a little pack that you put on a camera that has a little gyroscope and accelerometer in there
You'll track the motion of that camera and let you stabilize your footage in post it's called SteadXP.
Now the thing is there's some caveats; One. You have to calibrate this for your lens each time
The second thing is you need to be able to sync up the data from this little
Accelerometer device with your footage but if this stuff was built in to for example, the black magic, that'd be awesome
You know, I'm already using black magic resolve to edit and manage all my black magic footage
so if they could build that into the camera just a little bit of an accelerometer and
Gyroscope and some sort of way to profile your lenses you can have this all synced up
You can just check a box and your editing program and suddenly your footage would be stable
Man, when you're going you're spending as much on a camera as like a Tesla Model 3
I kind of expect some these things a Tesla can drive itself the red can't even pull good autofocus
One thing that burns my biscuits is the lack of good autofocus
in modern cameras here at the studio what we film on our Canon DSLRs that have awesome dual
pixel autofocus that reacts very quickly and effectively they also
Have a touch auto focus, which allows you to select a part of your screen here and focus on that particular area
It's really cool really effective
I use an a7 three at home for photo and video and it has very good face detection that by actually
Highlighting the eyes and knowing the exact focal plane of within which a face is on
Now both of the Blackmagic and the red do have autofocus capabilities. The Reds are pretty much unusable
They're very very slow and very difficult to quickly access. We're talking about touch screens
We have this the massive chungus of the touch screen here on the red here
Just considering how much processing power is in this beast and the size of the touch screen
It seems silly that creating a good autofocus system is the last thing on the minds over at red
this thing could run Crysis practically but yet can't focus the
Blackmagic while slightly better only allows you to do kind of a generalized central spot
Autofocus and does get you halfway there
But when it comes to the day to day shooting doesn't really quite do the same thing
It doesn't perform the same way and it's technology that's out there. It's in the cheapest of cameras
It's everywhere Target and Best Buy a corner market, you'll find all the cameras with decent autofocus, but not here
that is one thing that these cameras really could benefit from
Okay, it's 2020, right
everyone's been going on about cameras and all these expensive cameras and the things that these cameras should be able to do
and I gotta say...
I Completely agree. It's 20/20
You pay thousands and thousands of dollars for a camera. Why can't a camera give you
A premium wireless earbud audio
experience like today's sponsor Raycon can?
For a hundred years people have been trying to figure out oh, whoa
What's the next upgrade we can do with a camera? What's the next best thing that it can give you?
Well, guess what? None of them can give you the audio experience that the Raycon E25 ear buds can.
They come in a stylish
charging carrying case that you can simply just slip into your pocket can a red camera or a black magic
camera give you the audio experience of a premium wireless earbuds available at about half the price of other premium wireless earbuds
No, it can't they don't come in fun colors and patterns like these earbuds. Do I mean come on think about it?
It's 2020. You spend all this money on the camera and you can't even get it in the color that you want
So if you guys are interested in getting one of the best Raycom models yet the e25 right here has over six hours of playtime
It has seamless bluetooth pairing and it comes in your favorite colors. So click the link in the description below to get
15% off your purchase this kind of technology seems seems like it should be happening now in 2020 if you ask me
All right. It's a quick timeout. Why are all these features missing from high-end cameras?
One of the main ones here is for example canon. They make a huge line of cameras. They make camcorders
They make DSLRs they make cinema cameras. They make a whole variety of cameras
And if they were to take all the good video features and put them into the DSLR
Well, you wouldn't have a reason to buy their camcorder line anymore
So there's a little bit of internal politics that prevent these companies from just making the singular best camera that can do everything
Now to be fair a singular tool that does everything is maybe not
something that exists
but that said the processing power should be there but it's not so there's a whole internal politics there as well as the fact that
If you make a camera too, good. Well, no one's gonna buy your next one
You know
I know it's the tinfoil hat time that we're kind of getting into but it's true if you put all the features into your
Current line, you're not gonna have another line to sell customers
So you have to make sure you keep a couple imperfections here that you can solve easily down the line
Another feature, I desperately need wireless monitoring. Hey, what's up?
I'm using it right now kind of. So, once again in the realm of problems that have already been solved but are for some reason
Non-existent in professional hardware, you got wireless monitoring. But Nico? professional hardware has wireless monitoring? You're right.
The problem is if you wanna do wireless monitoring these days you have to get a module
Slap it to the side of the camera, figure out a way to power it, get another module
slap it to the side of your monitor, figure out a way to power that, and then link the two together.
and you finally have a system
but that's a lot of extra hardware and you know what? GoPro, God bless their hearts.
I can connect my phone to this little camera and I can see it an image on my phone
I can wirelessly monitor from my GoPro using my phone.
Granted, there's a lot of latency and compression but man if this thing can do it for 400 bucks
You sure would expect that a twenty thousand dollar camera could do it, right?
it wasn't until recently that small HD had the genius idea of
packaging a tarot deck and a monitor together in the same thing to make one convenient slim little package and this is
One of the best tools I've ever used this just mounts on your camera this a regular monitor has two little rabbit ears come off
The top and then boom your director your lighting person
Anybody can have another monitor and they can view what's happening through the camera it is so so so convenient and yet!
Why aren't they building it into these guys!? Or even these guys!?
But the fact they have a solution for me to wirelessly monitor with a GoPro for
$400 makes me wonder why camera manufacturers don't have a solution for five thousand, six thousand, twenty thousand,
thirty thousand dollar cameras? I can do with the small HT system
Why is it up to a third party to go out there and put all these solutions together?
My phone can do it and my GoPro can do it. Why can't my high-end cinema camera do it?
My personal gripe is that like no cameras have wireless audio like natively in the camera and I'm talking about both like
Monitoring audio but also like built-in wireless
Microphone audio pretty much everyone I know has some sort of wireless headphone of some sort whether it's Airpods, Raycons or those "Bonephones"
and they all hook up to our phones via Bluetooth standard stuff. It's been standard for a while
All you need is Bluetooth 4.0 just a regular run-of-the-mill modern Bluetooth chip
Hook that into the audio then I could just use my Bluetooth earbuds and monitor the audio
I can know whether or not I'm getting it without wires dangling everywhere and having that jack in
I don't know
It seems like such a simple thing and not a single camera that I know of
includes this if we're being real you don't have to have
Studio quality headphones to monitor your audio we're talking indie films
We're talking YouTube films if you're running like an actual feature indie project
You probably have your own audio guy doing their own wireless audio thing so you don't have to worry about that
This isn't really about that though. This is about just having the camera
They can monitor audio from with Wireless earbuds, come on!
Arghh
So, now I'm just
Demonstrating a 3d tracking of my phone and how it can
Track where it is in 3d space and let me composite things into the shot
So it's another great example of the fact I like my phone
The combination of accelerometers gyroscopes abilities and camera is able to maintain a three positional awareness of its position in space
now once again
None of the professional cameras can do that. Even in like the highest-end
Alexa's and Sony's and Red's have no sense of 3d tracking whatsoever and maybe this is just a byproduct
of the fact that it's a little bit of a visual effects kind of thing and camera manufacturers may not be prioritizing that
But imagine, if you will, that when you recorded for your camera
You also happen to get another file that records your cameras position in 3d space
So you can literally just be able to put an object into the scene anywhere. It'd be really really cool
It'd be super useful and especially for us when we're doing our visual effects to have real-time 3d tracking from your camera. First and foremost,
We wouldn't have to do 3d camera tracking
Afterwards and are doing visual effects, which requires us to track points in the image
So if you have really blurry image or it's dark
It's really impossible sometimes to get a 3d track of that. But it could just be built into the footage right from the get-go
The other thing is if you're filming on a green screen well
Imagine being able to film on a green screen and then instantly eye-dropper out the background and drop in a real-time 3d
Background that already tracks to your performance you could do any kind of movie you could do all the avatars
And you'd haven't done way way sooner than James Cameron is getting them done. VR headsets already can do this
The $400 Rift-S has the ability to inside out 3d tracking. That's how it tracks itself and yet the camera
That's the price of a Tesla Model 3 can't do it
Heck the camera is out of the price of 2 Tesla Model 3 can't do it the technology already exists in our hands in
These cameras so why isn't it there in the better cameras?
The thing is is that all of these things we've been talking about already
Exist in one form or another and yet they don't seem to exist in the actual tools
We need them for and there's probably some good reasons. I'm not I'm not wearing Nico's tinfoil hat
so it's there's probably legitimate good reasons why these things aren't actually included but at the same time it's like I
feel like most people these days are only focused on like the hard specs like, what resolution does this camera shoot? what frame rate?
how many stops of dynamic range? I care about how easy is this camera to use?
What are the features that will make it the best experience for me getting from shooting something to uploading it?
Okay, and obviously we're coming at this from the perspective of being like YouTube filmmakers
We don't have giant crews on our sets on film sets
You have like people operating cameras in a separate focus puller and a separate audio
Manager all kinds of different roles on set just to operate one camera
but the problem is that if you are just in any person wanting to use this as like a single person rig you have some
Sacrifices and usability and that's just a little unfortunate considering that technology is out there to implement right now
I'm hoping that you know
maybe these marketing teams on these cameras start trying to drive a little less for resolution and more for like
How is the best way to use this camera if I was the only person using it?
And honestly, these are just a few of the ideas that we've thought up
But I'm actually very interested in hearing what you guys think you'd like to see in a camera in 2020
Leave a comment down below with your ideas. If all these things came together, that would be the camera
I'd expect to have my hands in the year 2020. That would be awesome
My phone can do like all these things. Will my professional camera be able to next year? We'll find out!